It sounds broken...
In 2018, the average American
will spend $600 on holiday gifts,
and total spending in the US will
top $700 billion. And more than
$100 billion of that spending will be
totally wasted, or as economists like to say,
those gifts will be a deadweight loss.
How can you avoid such a loss this year?
Economic theory provides a simple solution: Give cash!
Yale economist Joel Waldfogel — conducting
serious science — wrote a famous article that
estimated that between one-tenth and
one-third of holiday gift-giving is mismatched
compared to a cash gift. Waldfogel finds further
support from economist Steven Landsburg,
who says he's not sure why people give each other
store-bought gifts like clothing instead of cash,
because cash is never the wrong
size or color. So, clearly cash is always
the most efficient gift. But if
cash seems too impersonal,
consider the next most
economically efficient gift — a gift card.
Like cash, it's never the wrong size or color.
Do you think cash is an acceptable
holiday gift? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topic you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.